- All right, let's close out
day one of our eighties celebration
with something super bright and cheery.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat fun music)
So y'all might remember that tie dye
saw a huge resurgence in the eighties.
Designers even started incorporating
unique tie dye patterns
on runways worldwide.
Now a little boy in
Pennsylvania wants to ensure
the trend stays as popular as ever.
He's making and selling his own shirts,
but here's what makes him extra special.
He's actually splitting the profits
with one of his favorite charities.
Let's get him on the line right now.
Say hi to six-year-old
Tuukka, and his mama Tiffany
who watch on ABC23 in Johnstown.
What's up, y'all?
- Hi.
- I like your tie dye!
You look so good.
So how'd you get so into tie dye, Tuukka?
- I got a tie dye kit for my birthday.
- Mm-hmm.
I saw other people do it on YouTube
and it looked really cool.
- You're like my kids.
My kids are in love with
watching YouTube things.
So wait, tell us about your business.
So how did you make it into a business?
You give some to charity, right?
- Yes.
- [Kelly] Yeah? Do you
have fun making that?
- Tell her the rest, go ahead.
Tell Kelly about your business.
- I'm the CEO of Tie Dye by Tuukka.
- Uh-huh.
- I make
tie dye shirts, sweatshirts, hoodies
bandanas for dogs, baby
onesies for dogs and babies.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Tell Kelly why you're
making all of these.
- For a $2,000 Lamborghini.
(Kelly laughs)
(audience clapping)
- First of all, this is news.
You just found a $2,000 Lamborghini.
That's amazing.
Everyone's running out trying
to find that right now.
Wait, tell us about the business.
So, Tiffany, what do you do with it?
- So I am, as he likes to call
me, his personal assistant.
So mom and personal assistant.
I work primarily
on keeping track of all of his orders,
getting his inks together.
I work on his Facebook group.
Right now that's
the main place of getting these shirts,
is his Facebook group.
He is definitely the CEO.
Definitely the boss.
He makes all the big decisions.
Personal assistant over here,
to help with whatever he needs.
- I love that.
Well, Tuukka, like what,
where do you give the money?
Who do you give the money to?
- I give the money to local charities.
- Mm-hmm, and tell Kelly
who you donated to first.
- Your Safe Haven.
- Mm-hmm. Can you tell
her about Your Safe Haven?
- Oh, I love that.
- They go buy gift cards
and give the money,
and give the gift cards
to moms and kids
that don't have enough
money to buy groceries.
- Oh, that's so kind.
You have such a big heart
for such a young man.
I love it.
Thank you so much, Tuukka,
and thank you, Tiffany,
for joining us today.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
- [Tiffany] That's right. Thank you.
- All right, that's not all though.
Our season long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of Friction,
the go-to erasable pen of
The Kelly Clarkson Show,
wanna celebrate those creating fearlessly,
just like you Tuukka.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
Yeah!
- Say, "Thank you!"
- Thank you!
- Thank y'all, have a blessed day.